-Our next guest is
a six-time NBA all-star
for the Portland Trail Blazers
and a member of Team USA
men's basketball.
He stars in
"Space Jam: A New Legacy,"
which is in theaters
and on HBO Max this Friday
Let's take a look.
-Sheesh!
Dude could use a makeover.
Mm. Oh. Wow. Whoo!
Mm. Oh. Okay. Ha ha!
Word!
-♪♪ Now I make it,
do a backflip ♪♪
♪♪ Try to play me,
probably end up with a fat lip ♪
♪♪ And you know
I gotta stack chips ♪♪
♪♪ So you know what time it
if I tap wrist ♪♪
-Huh?
-[ Gasps ]
[ Glass shatters ]
-Ugh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Please welcome to the sho
Damian Lillard.
How are you, Dam?
-I'm good. How you doing?
-I'm doing very well. First,
congratulations on the film.
Obviously, you're an actor i
it, but even more impressively
for my money, you have
a song on the soundtrack.
How did that come about?
Which happened first.
-Well, they had me
in the movie first,
and then some people found out
that I do music,
and they was like, "Would yo
want to be a part of
the soundtrack?"
And I was like,
"Yeah, let's do it."
So they put me on
a Bay Area-inspired track
because I'm from the Bay Area.
-And you also --
you have an album coming out
this summer, as well,
so a pretty big musical moment
you're having.
-I am. Like, obviously,
I play basketball.
I'm an actor now.
And music is a big part
of my life,
so it's going to be my fourt
album coming in August.
-Do your teammates
and fellow NBA players,
are they fans of your music?
Do you get a lot
of feedback on it?
-At the beginning, they wa
kind of hating on my music
They was like, "You think
you're a rapper,"
all this kind of stuff.
And then when they started
to listen, they was like,
"You can actually rap."
So now they look forward to it
-Now, the thing that I would b
the most afraid of
would be them coming to yo
and asking if they could
also rap on your albums.
Has that happened yet?
And what do you say?
-They have.
Like, a few of them come like,
"Let me get on the track,"
and then I'll be like, "Cool."
And when it's time to do it,
they back out, so...
-That's --
that's a good outcome.
So the first "Space Jam" cam
out when you were 6 years old.
It seems like that might b
the sweet spot
for a kid who loves basketball
Do you remember seeing the film?
Were you a fan?
-I was a huge fan.
I had the merch -- the t-shirts,
the shoes, everything. I had it.
So, to be a part of the sequel
you know, is a dream come true
-Your kids -- I know you hav
twins who are very young.
They're six months old.
Congratulations.
You got a 3-year-old.
Is he gonna see it,
or has he seen it yet?
-He watched it with me
the first time,
and he wasn't
really interested
until they got to, like,
the Looney Tunes part.
He watched that, and then
when it went back to real life
he was disinterested again
But I think now that
he's a little bit older --
That was probably
like six months ago.
And I think now that
he's a little more mature,
he'll -- he'll see
what's going on better.
Now I think
he'll really like it.
-I want to warn you,
'cause a lot of my friends
when they do films
that are kid-friendly,
their kids are very upset
when they see
their parents in it,
They don't like it 'cause
it takes them out of the world
-I think my son --
I think now he'll like it.
When he see me on TV,
like, playing basketball
or even when I watched
the movie with him,
he was like, you know,
"That's other Daddy.
Like, he don't think it's me
He just think that's, like
another version of me, so...
-Well, I mean, I will say,
he would certainly be allowe
to think that,
based on the animation her
of your character, Chronos
Was it -- It must have been cool
to see that for the first time
-Yeah, it was real cool.
I was --
It was a process
trying to figure out, like
how the character would look
You know, there were so many
different stages,
and I was like --
certain things
I didn't really like,
so it was a process to get i
to look how I wanted it to look.
So I'm happy that it turned out,
you know?
As soon as you see it,
you can tell it's me.
-This is your first movie,
not your first acting gig.
I was thrilled
when I first saw you appea
in my colleague Fred Armisen's
show "Portlandia."
I mean, it made sense
because you were in Portland
but how did it come about?
-Well, they had a history
of having the Trail Blazer
involved in the show.
And it wasn't really acting.
It was just, like, coming
through the tunnel at halftime
just kind of
a basketball environment.
And they asked me
would I want to do it,
so the first time I did it
I did it with teammates.
And then, the next time,
it was like, "All right,
I want to be
just thrown into the show.
I don't want to be in an arena
in uniform
or anything like that.
I just want to be there."
And they was like,
"Cool. Let's do it."
So I was like, "Let's do it.
Let me get my acting caree
started."
-I'm glad that you could
be helped by Fred
in an acting career,
but based on everything
I've seen from him,
you did not help
his sports career at all.
-At all.
I was just his, like, friend
That was it.
-Hey, Chad Johnson,
former NFL superstar Ochocinco
he made news recently.
He went to a Portland IHOP
and he left a --
I want to leave the last par
for the end.
So he left a -- right there --
a $1,000 tip on a $33 bill
and that was in the news.
But then he also wrote
at the bottom, "I love you
I beat Damian Lillard
in one-on-one
years ago in the YMCA."
Is that true, Dam.
-It is literally
a straight-up lie.
He literally made that up.
I saw him one time at a --
after our graduation in Oregon
in the parking lot,
and he was like, "Man,
let's play some pickup.
Let's go hoop."
And I was like, "Let me know."
And he was like, "All right,
I'm gonna let you know."
That was it.
We never played.
I haven't seen him since.
And he just made that up
randomly, so...
-It's a really funny way to li
because we're all kind of
predisposed to take his side
because of the really nice tip
he left.
-Right. Exactly.
He tried to buy their loyalt
with the tip, so...
-Hey, you're about
to head off to Tokyo.
Has it sunk in for you?
I mean, the season barely,
for you, just ended,
and now you're off
to represent Team USA.
How are you feeling?
-I feel good.
I think it's definitely
a commitment.
But coming up short
in the NBA season,
it's like, instead of
having a long off-season
where you thinking about
what went wrong,
what you could have done
differently,
jumping right back in
to meaningful games
and doing something
that's bigger than myself
and being able to have
an opportunity
to be a gold medalist
is worth it.
So, you know, I'm excited
to be headed there.
-Big weekend for you.
Movie coming out.
It's your birthday.
Happy birthday on behalf o
everybody here at "Late Night.
-Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Any plans, any birthday plan
before you go to Japan?
-Y'all gonna sing
"happy birthday" to me?
-No, we don't have anyone here
So, no.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't -- I mean,
I'll probably have dinner
with some family,
something light.
But that's it. Nothing crazy
-Well, we really appreciat
you making the time.
Congrats on the film.
Congrats on the album.
Best of luck in Tokyo.
We hope you bring back the gold.
And we look forward
to seeing you next time.
-Thank you. Thank you.
I appreciate it.
-"Space Jam: A New Legacy"
premieres in theaters
and on HBO Max tomorrow.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."